I think of his films yeah you must think
I'm pretty sick or something the one
that really moved me the most was uh was
taxi driver I think to take people to
the Bronx Brooklyn I take them to Harlem
I don't care I remember watching it at
15 years old and and being transfixed
with Travis Bickle because I was I was
um locked into this character and I felt
such incredible empathy towards I
understood him I understood his
loneliness and then he deceived me
employment and inflation and at the
point he deceived me I said what who is
this guy that I'm watching and I I was
identifying with with him and I was with
him on this whole journey and all of a
sudden this is not the person that I
thought he was and and and to me it's
just really the greatest
um independent film of them it really is
Schrader's uh extraordinary pulse rate
pulse rate of script I think you had
something to do with it yeah Paul Paul
went through a lot on that one he he did
a beautiful deliberate this just it was
amazing